نحن نعلم أن إسرائيل وصفت
أفعالها بأنها دفاع عن النفس في أعقاب
الفظائع التي ارتكبها
الجناح العسكري لحماس ضد المدنيين
والجنود الإسرائيليين، لكن الدفاع عن النفس
مقيد أيضًا بالقانون الدولي
ولا يمكن أن يشمل صراحةً إجراءات انتقامية أو عقابية بموجب القانون الدولي.  لم
يُسمح مطلقًا بتبرير الإبادة الجماعية
باسم الدفاع عن النفس، لذا لا يمكن أن يكون هناك أي
مبرر لهذا
العقاب الجماعي الوحشي للفلسطينيين في
غزة، وهناك الآن أيضًا
مخاوف مبررة تعبر عنها
مؤسسات حقوق الإنسان الرائدة التي تحت غطاء
هذا الهجوم  وفيما يتعلق بغزة، فإن
الطرد المستمر للفلسطينيين من
منازلهم في الضفة الغربية سوف يتكثف
بشكل كبير وأن إسرائيل على
وشك الشروع في عملية
تطهير عرقي جماعية، ونحن
نشهد بالفعل وضعًا عنيفًا بشكل لا يصدق
في الضفة الغربية الآن في الضفة الغربية.  في
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية، كانت هناك
غارات عسكرية إسرائيلية واسعة النطاق على
البلدات الفلسطينية والقرى ومخيمات اللاجئين،
وزيادة كبيرة في أعمال العنف التي يرتكبها
المستوطنون الإسرائيليون، علاوة على ذلك، تم سجن
1350 فلسطينيًا آخرين من غزة يحملون
تصاريح للعمل في إسرائيل.  يشار
إليهم الآن
في وسائل الإعلام الإسرائيلية كأسرى حرب
ونحن نتعلم يوما بعد يوم أه
التقارير عن الانتهاكات التي
يتعرضون لها في المعتقلات الآن إسرائيل
منذ 56 عاما تمارس احتلالا غير قانوني
في جميع أنحاء فلسطين وهذا
ببساطة ليس جيدا  يكفي أن
يدعو قادتنا السياسيون إلى
احترام القانون الدولي فقط عندما نعلم أن
الحكومة الإسرائيلية تصرفت لعقود من الزمن
في تجاهل للقانون الدولي
في سياق
احتلالها العسكري لفلسطين، لذا فإن هذا في جوهره
ليس مجرد عمل إنساني فحسب.  إن
الأزمة ذات أبعاد بالغة في غزة ولكنها
أزمة سياسية فيما يتعلق
بفلسطين ككل، وفي حين أن
المطلوب الآن هو وقف فوري
لإطلاق النار في غزة، فإن هذا يجب أن
يتبعه الاعتراف بأن
أحداث الأسابيع الثلاثة الماضية أدت
إلى  نقلة نوعية كاملة في
فلسطين وإسرائيل، وهذا له
آثار حقيقية على الطريقة التي
واصل بها المجتمع الدولي
معالجة هذه
الأزمة